let's instead try billy from california
billy from california you're on the air
hey david hey you hear me
yes oh sorry hey hey
i just wanted to talk quickly about uh
actually masking so
you know based on cdc guidelines if
you're vaccinated now you don't have to
wear a mask outside
i started working in my downtown office
again since i've been fully vaccinated
and i'm walking to the office every day
and i'm not wearing my mask
but i see everyone else wearing a mask
and i almost feel like obligated to do
so just kind of like
i don't know like a sense of camaraderie
or like hey i'm i'm
like you know trying to be safe and look
out for other people too but now hold on
when you're
so weird when you say you walk into your
office not wearing a mask you're not
saying
inside the masks are still required
right you're saying outside
oh sure sure no i meant like i park you
know away from the office
as i'm walking through downtown to my
office
there's uh you know people wearing masks
and that and you know you walk by them
and they kind of look at you funny if
you're not wearing a mask and it's like
hey like
i'm back you know you don't want to just
start shouting people on your
vaccinations i'm vaccinated yeah
no i know i'm seeing the same thing in a
lot of different places i mean listen
here's the deal
um if there's a line at the grocery
store and i'm standing outside
in the line and everybody's wearing a
mask i'm going to put the mask on
because that's kind of like a specific
situation and so i want to be kind of
part of the team
when i go out running now there's still
a lot of people wearing masks
and i'm not wearing a mask you know i am
fully vaccinated
i don't think we ever really needed
masks in that situation i
but i followed the cdc guidelines all
along i continue to follow them i think
and and i have a high level of comfort
nobody has given me a dirty look but if
they did
i wouldn't care i'd be totally
comfortable i'm doing what the cdc says
sure so i think it's a very personal
thing
some people are more impacted by the
social pressure some are not
i think the important thing is are we
following the guidelines
fair enough yeah and i well i agree and
i guess downtown's a little different
because you do have
it's not crowded yeah but at the same
time it's not sparse so when you're
walking down the sidewalks you are like
a few feet from people
but again the data shows that that's low
transmission rate
yeah you know the thing i'm also
wondering is that when i see
that even though the guidelines have
changed i'm wondering number one
are these people aware of the change but
they're just not vaccinated
sure so that's why they're doing it or
have people not even heard about the
change yet that's also possible
that's the other thing too like maybe
we're more and obviously we're more in
tune to it
right you would read the news and stuff
like that but i don't think
everybody does that i don't think
there's been a big i haven't seen any
cam you know ads or psas um really
saying
things i agree there's been no
commercials saying you no longer have to
wear your mask outside i think over the
next couple months though it'll roll out
and you'll see
fewer and fewer outdoor masks yeah
um another thing too if you just for a
minute um
as as we're kind of reopening and
getting back together like
we finally were able to visit with my
family
you know uh my brother my sisters and uh
my mom and my dad
since everyone's fully vaccinated you
know we brought our kids over there and
it was
you know really great to be around them
but you know as we're going forward and
kind of reopening and getting back
together with people
yeah i do still have some family members
that are
are maga or or anti-vaxxers and i know
they're not going to get the vaccine and
it just kind of hurts because it's like
well i want to see these people and i
want to be around these people
right and i don't really have any ill
will as like a
you know family to family but i mean
that's
gonna be tough there's i've heard a lot
of stories like that where i know so
many people
i don't personally know anyone not
getting vaccinated but lots of the
people i know
do know people not getting vaccinated
and many of them are saying
we've just told them we will only be
around you
outside if you're not vaccinated period
some are being even more extreme and
saying listen i'm just not going to see
you at all
but a lot a lot i know are saying listen
we're just going to have to see each
other outside if you refuse to get
vaccinated
yeah yeah and it's tough you know with
with young kids i
i my wife and i are pretty protective so
i don't even know if we would
become too comfortable with that sure to
each their own but
going to be interesting going forward
all right my friend thank you for the
call
take care uh i hope you're doing well
because you didn't mention
that you were doing well before you
started calls so you know
i'm doing well thank you for asking yeah
very good okay
all right thanks everybody i will see
you soon uh okay
a lot of concern for whether i am doing
well today
most healthy granola bars have sort of a
bad reputation because they're either
dry or boring or don't taste that good
or
they don't satisfy your cravings but our
sponsor monk pack
is completely different because monk
pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious with a soft and chewy texture
and yet they have only 140 calories one
gram of sugar
and only two to three net carbs perfect
for the low sugar
or keto diet they come in fantastic
flavors like coconut cocoa
chip blueberry almond vanilla
and the new flavor peanut butter i've
been a fan for a long time i always have
them in my pantry
it is a perfect snack and if you don't
love them as much as i
do you get all your money back they also
now have a
subscription feature which i love it'll
save you 10 on every order
and it ships automatically you'll get 20
off when you go to monkpack.com and use
the coupon code
pacman the link is right underneath this
video